le désert du sahara dans le sud marocain
des dunes à perte de vue qu'il faut
gravir sur 250 km depuis 30 ans le
marathon des sables attire chaque année
un millier de coureurs d'une
cinquantaine de nationalités dans ce
décor d'exception hommes et femmes vont
lutter contre la chaleur le sable
pendant cinq jours
un peu plus de 2000 kilomètres de là
claudine amat s'entraîne dans les lignes
de sancerre à 57 ans elle s'est lancé le
défi de participer à cette course hors
normes
ce jour là il fait 5 petits degrés le
vent souffle en rafales et a vraiment un
très très bon terrain de jeu pour
s'entraîner si vous avez des les coteaux
ça monte ça descend il ya des cailloux
donc c'est vraiment un très bon terrain
il manque le sable évidemment et je
compte pas par jour mon entraînement je
compte par semaine donc je cours environ
deux cents à 110 kilomètres par semaine
depuis le mois de janvier
quand je cours dans les vignes je pense
forcément marathon jeu forcément que j'y
arriverai au bout je vois arriver au
bout je rêve même de le gagner
s'il aventures du marathon des sables
est d'abord personnelle
claudine a tenu à courir pour une cause
qui lui tient particulièrement à coeur
l'évolution du statut des femmes dans le
monde
un combat que le zonta club mène depuis
longtemps cette ong internationale
existe depuis presque cent ans à bourges
daniel fait partie des premières
antienne claudine nous a fait part de
son projet quand on a vu effectivement
que le le marathon qui est quand même
très important que s'il ya 1400
participants il y avait que 14 % de
femmes
voilà vous avez la réponse
on a dit c'est important qu'une qu'une
ancienne cour puisse l'aider pour
qu'elle puisse participer à ce marathon
on sait que c'est quelqu'un qui aime les
défis qui aiment les grandes
compétitions c'était un troll de l'aider
financièrement et psychologiquement et
de l'encourager le plus possible dans sa
démarche
claudine aime les défis c'est peu dire
elle a déjà participé à cinq rallye des
gazelles
en 2010 elle a même remporté cette
compétition qui a lieu aussi dans le
désert marocain
je me suis décidée en 2014 et quand je
me suis décidé à partir de ce moment je
me suis mis dans la tête donc ça plus
été une épreuve folk et je me disais
qu'ils étaient malades de faire ce genre
de truc c'est des fous enfin bon mais à
partir du moment où je me suis mis dans
la tête était terminée et là c'était
courir pour levante a donc voilà de
représenter la femme sur une épreuve
masculine de montrer que nous aussi
femmes on peut le faire est de défendre
le statut de la femme dans le sport pour
moi la femme est l'égal de l'homme quoi
voilà depuis qu'elle sait qu'elle a été
sélectionnée pour l'une des épreuves les
plus éprouvantes au monde
claudine prépare son départ
méthodiquement contrairement à d'autres
personnes elles ne possèdent pas de
coach sportif
alors c'est ici qu'elle vient chercher
des précieux conseils sur des efforts
assez long l'idée c'est de cette
garantir une certaine marge pour éviter
des soucis de brûlures dans pool ou
d'irritations notamment au niveau des
ongles mon défi c'est de partir sans
côte voilà beaucoup de personnes partent
avec un code personnel et moi de partir
son côté donc pour moi je pensais que ça
aurait été plus difficile que ça et ça
quand même fédérer ce projet créerait
beaucoup de gens
les gens sont venus sont pas avares de
me renseigner quoi on va juste regarder
en terme de show sans une pointure le
physique doit tenir le coup pendant
toute la semaine donc ça demande quand
même un certain entraînement ce n'est
pas à prendre à la légère
donc raison pour laquelle claudine
aujourd'hui on lui a conseillé d'avoir
un volume d'entraînement assez
conséquent pour arriver en bonne forme
et puis près temps d'aller au bout de
son effort en tout cas pour participer
au marathon des sables bien s'équiper
est une priorité mais pas seulement
pendant cinq jours chaque coureur est en
autosuffisance alimentaire et chacun
doit porter son équipement pendant toute
la durée de la course
alors chaque gramme compte je suis
arrivé à 8 kg 5
mais en revanche pour moi ça va être
trop lourd ça j'ai encore pas fini il me
manque l'appareil photo il manque deux
ou trois trucs et qui vont peser lourd
donc ça va me faire dépasser 2 9 kg est
vraiment faut que j'aurais dû par
exemple ça c'est ma trousse de toilette
pour ses joues roses à l'égard de la
passe avait ainsi alors j'ai prévu les
lingettes les lingettes les lingettes
sont mises dans le monde et dans le
commerce doc humide je dois voir le
sachet site
donc c'est très lourd donc j'ai pris mes
la jette je vais aller je les ai été
séché et je les empaqueter donc là c'est
pas lourd du tout 73 g donc je suis
vraiment à la chasse aux graves 73 g si
je pouvais même trois grammes c'est trop
trop parce que je veux vraiment pas
dépasser ou qu'ils ont fait pendant ces
longs foulée dans le sien c'est roy
claude il peut compter sur ses amis pour
la soutenir
philippe l'a rejoint dès qu'il peut
ensemble ils ont monté un club
d'athlétisme
c'est une battante c'est
à ténacité incarner quoi parmi tous les
gens que je connais dans le club
c'est vraiment là celle qu'il ira
jusqu'au bout si on a une qui
abandonnera jamais le marathon des
sables ces six étapes de 30 à 75 km
empruntant les plus beaux terrains du
désert marocain
un challenge physique mais aussi mentale
qu'il faudra gérer car cette épreuve
n'est pas seulement un exploit sportif
c'est aussi une démarche presque
philosophique où chaque coureur vient se
dépasser et vivre des émotions fortes
vous allez découvrir le petit mot casser
la gueule je tais tu nous quittais
dessous j'ai certainement pas ses
partenaires plein de ce padd possible
découvrir une autre
claudine à découvrir quelques uns je
connais pas qui dort en moi
qui va peut-être aidé à me comprendre et
puis aussi le sport pas le sport cette
compétition j'aime ça courir ses
couleurs chaudes ce désert jacques